good morning Hank it's Friday July 27th
and I have really exciting news that
might have been too much it's not that
exciting
I have reasonably exciting news actually
after the excitement of the last couple
days that's probably even too much Hank
I have news that I find exciting that
you probably won't that's right I
finished cataloging my home library yes
this is something I've wanted to do ever
since we left New York when I had to
pack up all those books I said to myself
when we move I am going to make a
brilliantly cataloged library so that I
will never lose another book again in my
entire life
and now with the help of library thing
calm and the New York Public Library's
guide to organizing a home library in
your pants I've done it that's right I'm
gonna book about how to organize your
library this is off topic but I wonder
exactly how many books can fit inside
the library in my pants I know that
right now the flamers are all like
flexing their little flame fingers
preparing to write you are a nerd hey
guy have a serious question why is being
a nerd bad saying I noticed you're a
nerd is like saying hey I noticed that
you'd rather be intelligent than be
stupid that you'd rather be thoughtful
than be vapid that you believe that
there are things that matter more than
the arrest record of Lindsay Lohan why
is that in fact it seems to me that most
contemporary insults are pretty lame
even lame is kind of lame saying you're
lame is like saying you walk with a limp
yeah whatever so does 50 cent he's done
all right for himself it's not that I
mind being insulted it's that I mind
being insulted so poorly there are
plenty of great insults I mean you could
be like you are way too focused on
yourself you want to talk about some
insults let's talk about Shakespeare's
insults I mean here's a conversation of
contemporary insults you're a dork
you're a geek you suck no you suck
compare that with the conversation made
out of real Shakespearean insults I
think that you're heard boils and
plagues you monstrous malefactor mad
headed pukes talking you stuffed cloak
bag of guts
you're just a huge bombard of sack you
barren spoiled man you carcass fit for
hounds dude carcass fit for hounds
that's a burn yeah I know right
carcass fit for hounds not bad you
valuet flea you falen ugly witch oh shut
up you presumptuous vassal you fat and
greasy citizen you saucy Lackey you
fancy monger oh yeah well you're a
mildewed ear
you're a timorous wrench maybe so but
you're a foul misshapen stigmatic with
an odiferous stench you fell undigested
womp wake up of what Shakespeare didn't
specify maybe like big league chew
that's disgusting I'm just like a pound
of big league chew sitting in somebody's
stomach now that's how you insult people
with Shakespeare nerdfighters for the
win Hank I'll see you on Monday oh wait
I forgot to show you my home library
hooray home library ok Hank we start off
with Shakespeare poetry reference
reference reference pin we got Aslam we
got wicker basket then we got
Christianity you have to separate them
with the wicker basket so they don't get
mad at each other and we've got Chinese
religions and then we've got some
history and social sciences author
copies of an abundance of katherines
author copies of Looking for Alaska
foreign editions of both books and
children's books then in the main room
we have first editions of contemporary
fiction literary biography southern
studies then up here we got novels by
dead guys stuff Mark Twain wrote and
travel then we have novels by living
authors we have young adult fiction
mystery novels literary criticism and of
course humor and then over here we have
my collection of first editions of books
that are about conjoined twins